Let's take a look at what it will take
to implement a very basic SyncAdapter.
We're going to write two services.
Each service serves the primary purpose
of delivering an object that represents
an Android Binder interface
to one of the system frameworks.
A Binder is actually the low-level glue
that implements cross process
cross process communication in Android.
You've been using Binders
every time you talk
to an Android system service.
Intents and content providers
are just high-level abstractions
on top of the Binder interface.
There's a whole language known
as AIDL to help define these interfaces.
We're not going to cover all this here,
but there's a lot more you can do
with services and Binders.
One more thing before we start,
we're going to define
an Authenticator Service
and an Authenticator.
But it will only be used
by the Android accounts framework
to allow us to create an account.
SyncAdaptor's need an account.
And the account framework requires
that there be an authenticator
delivered by an authenticator Service.
You'll see that our authenticator
is just a series of stubs,
with exceptions that get thrown
for each call just to prove
that it isn't really used.
One final note.
This section approximately
follows the online training
at developer.android.com
around sync adapters.
Feel free to look there if you have
any more questions.
We're going to create a new package, sync,
to house all of this goodness.
And a new class file
for our authenticator.
This code that we're about
to paste in really just comes
from the developer.android.com website,
and as I mentioned earlier,
it's just a stub.
You can tell because
we throw exceptions for calling
any of the functions
except for the constructor.
And one more file.
Create SunshineAuthenticatorService.
This is more code that is written for us.
It allows the account manager
to access the empty authenticator
that we just pasted in.
Now we add the account type
in our strings.xml.
The account type string suggests
that it is specific to our app.
If we had many applications
using the same account,
we might want to create
just an example.com account.
We'll also begin to clean things up
and add a content authority string.
Note that this matches
our content provider string.
We'll fix the XML file later
so they both use this same string.
We create a new XML resource file,
filename authenticator.xml,
with root element account-authenticator.
And you probably noticed
that SunshineAuthenticatorService
is actually a service
that needs to be registered
with a package manager
in AndroidManifest.xml.
Here's some more pastey goodness
that does just that.
Now be very, very careful.
These strings all have to match precisely.
The error messages that the system
gives for having incorrect accounts
are not necessarily intuitive.
And with that,
you should be able
to create valid accounts.
Once again, this is all just
so that the SyncAdapter
can be tied to an account.
You don't actually use this at all.
All right, let's tweak our provider tag
in the manifest.
We're going to add the syncable attribute.
This just let's Android know
that we're planning to synchronize
the content provider with the server.
Also, we'll set android:exported
equals false.
We had it at the default setting,
which means that other apps
could see our content.
Finally, let's change the authority
to use our new string.
Now, for some additional permissions.
We need to be able
to read and write sync settings.
That makes sense.
We also have to authenticate accounts,
even though we're not really using them
for anything.
None of these permissions are ones users
should be concerned about.
But as developers, we always want
to be careful when we have
to add new permissions.
Let's create the SunshineSyncAdapter
file itself inside of sync,
which extends the abstract threaded
sync adapter class.
Hit Ctrl+I and then Ctrl+O
to implement the necessary abstract
methods in constructor.
We'll use the first constructor.
We'll fill this out later.
As you may recall, the sync adaptor
pattern requires yet another service.
So we're going to create
another Java class
called SunshineSyncService.
This class is used to deliver the sync
adapter Binder to the sync manager.
The Binder is implemented for us by
the abstract threaded sync adapter class.
And returned in the
getSyncAdapterBinder method.
And now, we need one more XML file.
Create syncadapter.xml
with root element sync-adapter.
Once again, this XML file defines the
settings associated with our sync-adapter,
including it's content authority.
The account type that it syncs.
Whether or not it's user visible.
Whether it supports uploading,
which changes the way the content provider
interacts with the sync adapter.
Allowing parallel syncs
and is always syncable.
These settings make sense
for this particular application,
and I bet you know what comes next.
You're right.
You have to register
the sync adapter service
with the package manager.
And therefore we have to create
more manifest entries,
containing some important metadata.
Most importantly, links
to the file we just created.
All right, now we're getting close.
Let's start working
on the sync adapter, itself.
We'll start with a helper function
to get the dummy sync account
and make sure that it has been created.
Then, we'll add another helper function
to our sync adaptor,
to make it easier
to test our sync adaptor.